[Música]
mira pues te amamos por una onda
nosotros queremos tres mil varas con una
tierra sino ya sabes mostrarle a una
consola probarlo si no te tiramos un par
de un vaso sí
violencia
temor esto es lo que nos generan estos
tipos de audios estos tipos de llamadas
que a diario en nuestra región se recibe
a miles de personas
qué es qué piensas cuando escuchas un
audio así piensas del delincuente
criminal privado de libertad pero ahora
estás cuestionando cómo es que tú puedes
entender esta situación tú eres de un
extranjero gringa tú no entiendes eso
eso es nuestra realidad pero no está
tuya pues les puedo decir hoy que tengo
15 años trabajando adentro de las
cárceles de guatemala 15 años trabajando
con las personas que realicen llamadas
así
en estos 15 años una de ellas tres veces
yo estaba trabajando en la cárcel de
máxima seguridad que aún trabajamos en
la cárcel de máxima seguridad en estos
años era alrededor de 2012 y el estado
tenía control total de la cárcel los
privados de libertad estaban aislados
los 24 horas al día y solo una hora una
hora a la semana tenían permiso a salir
al patio de la cárcel a tomar luz pero
no era como uno se piensa en que salen a
convivir y lo que se salían y tenían que
afiliarse y caminar en círculos una hora
con la cabeza agachada no tenían permiso
entrar dentro actuar no tenía permiso
convivir solo caminar en círculos y yo
hasta la gringa era la única persona que
estaba permitido entrar a esta cárcel a
dar rehabilitación me sacaban grupos
pequeños de tres y bordaban gorras
planos a mano y era muy bonito
los muchachos disfrutaban mucho este
habilitación y después de unos meses de
estar haciendo bien el proyecto por fin
sistema penitenciario prueba para que yo
puedo sacar los muchachos a jugar fútbol
imagínense dos días dos años encerrados
dos años encerrados y por ti me iban a
tener permiso a salir a jugar fut era
una sorpresa por supuesto entonces el
día que yo llegó ellos no saben y ese
día yo voy a la oficina del director
mientras que la guardia preparan porque
recuerden se tenía mucho tiempo de no
haber sacado a los privados entonces
estoy sentada en la piscina con el
director me están seguían los vídeos en
su computadora del año 99 yo no sé yo
pero me está enseñando a estos vídeos de
ser militar y desde tiempo de la
guerrilla y de repente se escucha una
explosión
y yo dije eso no fue de este vídeo
porque este computadora es sencillo no
tiene un audio otro mundo eso sí fue
algo y el director rápido se levanta de
su escritorio y me vea y abre la puerta
de su oficina y la guardia estaba
corriendo para arriba para abajo
gritando motín motín y el director me
vuelta a ver qué me dice gringa te
quedas aquí y si eres la fuerte de su
oficina me echa llave adentro de dos
vecinas y no no te voy a decir que yo
tenía miedo más bien tenía shock yo
escuchaba tras sus gritos y escuchaba
explosión tras explosión pero no era
explosiones normales eran que están
atropellando puertas puerta pasto fue
puerta cada vez más cerca de la oficina
donde estaba y yo y yo decía a la gran
yo no puedo esperar que estos hijos
llegan a mí me van a violar me van a
matar saber qué sé yo y empiezo a
voltear a ver la oficina y yo veo que
hay una ventana
no vayan a creer que es gran cosa estaba
en el primer nivel del edificio pero era
de estas ventanas que solo se abre en la
parte de arriba entonces yo digo yo me
voy a salir de ahí y voy a estar a salvo
entonces yo meneo una una silla hacia la
ventana subo y bajó al otro lado a mi
salvación no estoy afuera pero no estoy
de acuerdo de la cárcel yo escucho más
ruido y vuelto a verla tarazá y en la
terraza hay pandilleros corriendo y
privados de libertad corriendo gritando
yo a la grande me van a agarrar más
fácil no estoy enterada y un privado de
libertad se da cuenta que yo estoy abajo
y me grita el gringo qué haces aquí y yo
pues yo les traje fútbol porque les iba
a premiar por su buen comportamiento y
el vino gringa nos hubiera avisado te
hubiera dicho que no llegara eso hoy y
yo
y dice sabes que mira andate a esta
esquina que está allá ahí quiero que te
quedas y te cuidas hasta que este 12
termina y me voy a la esquina y me quedo
ahí hasta que el pedo se termina y les
quiero decir de que gracias a dios ese
día no había muerte si había heridos
pero me salí a salvo
pero la pregunta es por qué soy gringa
es obvio no lo puedo esconder porque es
que ellos no me hicieron daño vamos a
pensar un momento como delincuentes si
ves una persona extranjero estás motín
'no hay alguna razón detrás de por qué
están motivando yo creo que la razón
aquí es obvio están luchando para sus
derechos humanos para poder tener que
siguió más rehabilitación tiempo en el
sol pero ellos fácilmente me podrían
agarrar y decir no volvimos a este
gringa hasta que nos das tal cosa o no
eso es lo que pienso yo o darnos nuestra
libertad a cambio de la gringa pero no
lo hicieron
por qué
se me llega a nuestra constitución de la
política de la república de guatemala yo
voy a ser sincera con ustedes
la primera vez que yo leía esta
constitución hace varios años la
constitución considerada más su mente
humanista del mundo con más de 200
artículos sobre los derechos humanos yo
dije adentro de mí que constitución más
hipócrita
sabemos que los derechos no cumplen
sabemos de derecho de estudio sabemos
que eso no está cumpliendo en el
interior de nuestro país ni hablamos de
salud donde las personas apenas pueden
estar atendido en los hospitales
públicos de guatemala derechos humanos
derechos humanos no existe en guatemala
decidió pero llegué hasta mi quinto año
de derecho cuando yo aprendí a admirar
esta constitución tener lo respeto pero
porque en mi quinto año estábamos
leyendo sobre la teoría de robert alexy
su teoría de la pretensión de corrección
de qué se trata esta teoría
esta teoría habla de constituciones de
muchos países que tienen derechos de no
se cumplan pero no es para que está ahí
solo para ver en papel y no practicar
las país los países que tienen eso los
desempleos constituyentes pensaron y
reconocieron los fallos los abusos y las
violaciones en sus derechos le dijeron
no queremos corregirlo queremos hacerlo
mejor
en el año 85 cuando fue escrito nuestra
constitución estábamos en una transición
de un gobierno autoritario a un gobierno
democrática por la primera vez en la
historia de guatemala y la asamblea
constituyente pensaba en los de buses se
pensaba en cómo podemos corregirlo tal
vez hoy no pero en el futuro los
ciudadanos de guatemala tienen la
oportunidad de defender estos derechos
porque tienen una constitución que
tienen para llamar el derecho de estudio
el derecho de salud y sobre todo para
esta práctica el derecho de los privados
de libertad de rehabilitarse en el
artículo 19 de la constitución política
de la república de guatemala dice que
los privados de libertad tiene el
derecho de rehabilitarse mientras están
privados de su libertad tiene el derecho
de readaptarse para que en el día de
mañana cuando ellos logren tener su
suave su libertad ellos pueden salir
personas nuevos personas cambiados para
nuestros nuestros sociedades pero
decimos grande a eso no está cumpliendo
por qué
y esto me llega la siguiente punto que
es el departamento de estado de los eeuu
en su página
advierte a sus ciudadanos no llegar a
guatemala por la violencia por robo por
secuestro por la extorsión en este que
en estos tres delitos si estudias más 80
por ciento de estos delitos son
extorsión y si va más allá de la
extorsión 90 por ciento de las
extorsiones provienen de las cárceles de
guatemala
y eso es donde preguntamos porque ella
es que las personas no están
rehabilitando porque ellas que están
saliendo estos delitos es por esta
situación la cárcel la actualmente en
guatemala hasta 400 por ciento sobre
poblado las personas apenas tienen
espacio para dormir esta foto fue de
hace cinco años imagínense cómo está hoy
la cárcel construido para 236 mujeres y
está llegando a 1600 mujeres y yo
pregunté una de estas mujeres un día
porque es que se extorsiona porque es
que hacen eso y me dicen mira que venga
yo voy a ser sincera contigo yo solo por
estar aquí no significa que mi familia
aún no me necesita ahora ya tienen
comida gratis aún necesitan que yo les
ayuden sostenerlos y yo tengo opciones
una opción es verlos morir de hambre
otra opción es peor verlas ir a un lugar
seguro ya sabemos lo que pasó en el
lugar seguro hace unos años donde se
quemaron viva 40 niñas es peor para
ellas verlas morir de hambre y verlos en
un lugar seguro o podemos extorsionar y
podemos ver que nuestros hijos están
bien entonces yo preguntaba a ellas
porque mira qué pena yo las vi en esta
situación le decía cómo puedo ayudar qué
puedo hacer yo esperando la respuesta de
comida ropa de enero y las privadas de
libertad me respondan las mismas
personas me respondan gringa queremos
una oportunidad de trabajar y me dio
risa porque dije ustedes cómo van a
trabajar están en la cárcel y ellas ya
sabían su derecho constitucional
me dijeron tenemos derecho de
rehabilitar a través del trabajo digno o
nada queremos trabajar yo en que quieren
trabajar y me dicen queremos trabajar en
serigrafía y yo dije bueno temo le
trabajamos en serigrafía
hoy en día tenemos más de 105 personas
hombres y mujeres trabajando en lo que
es serigrafía y corte de confección y me
gustaría contarles que yo tengo el
programa más de todo el mundo pero no
soy la única hay otro programa en méxico
actualmente en la ciudad de méxico ha
sido un proyecto muy similar
rehabilitando mujeres con trabajo donado
y ellas tienen los mismos resultados que
tenemos aquí en guatemala con nuestros
privados de libertad 0% de redención que
nos quiere decir eso nuestra asamblea
constituyente cuando plasmó el artículo
19 en la constitución sabía que eso
funcionará y el resultado ha sido eso
las personas cuidaron a una gringa en
medio de una motín a donde la podían
utilizar para hacer mucho más la
cuidaron porque estaba ya en pequeña
escala cumpliendo lo que la constitución
tienen plasmada
la siguiente ejemplo es ella se llama
gabriela guzmán ella es uno de los 500
personas que han pasado por mi programa
de rehabilitación cuando ves esta foto
muchos me dicen pero bueno parece presa
arcediano parece ex privada de libertad
pues ella es una persona y su esposo los
dos estaban privados de libertad y los
dos aprovecharon el tiempo en la cárcel
para trabajar para estudiar y para
readaptar y salir personas nuevos muchos
de mis privados de libertad que trabajan
para mí siempre me dicen que su sueño en
la vida es sacar su familia adelante
salir de la zona roja y poder vivir en
una residencial pues hoy les puedo decir
con el ejemplo de gabi que es un ejemplo
de muchas que ya viven en una
residencial tienen un trabajo de tiempo
completo al igual que su esposo y los
tres hijos están estudiando de forma
virtual con sus propios laptop
es buenísimo
muchas personas dicen o están pensando
ustedes ahorita porque hay una foto del
palacio que tienen que ver este palacio
con su charla de privados de libertad lo
que muchos de ustedes tal vez no sabían
era que el palacio nacional de guatemala
una de las estructuras más bellos de
nuestro centro histórico en parte fue
construidos por privados de libertad y
lo más interesante de eso
es que es el mismo lugar donde vamos
como pueblo para exigir nuestros
derechos humanos plasmados en la
constitución es el mismo lugar donde
vamos a exigir nuestra libertad nuestros
derechos de libertad en un lugar
construido por privados de libertad
se dice que nadie conoce verdaderamente
una nación hasta que uno no ha estado
dentro de sus cárceles una nación no se
debe ser juzgado por la forma en que se
trata a sus ciudadanos más importantes
sino a las más bajas
gracias
[Aplausos]